well like with the free state project
last time i brought it up to malice i
was like hey are you going to pork fest
you're like no i'm like how dare you i
think we're going i think we're taking
this our video pork fest yeah if we can
get starling we can and i'll get it and
and don't worry about it that wasn't a
knock against the free state project
that was a knock against me being in the
woods
okay okay i just want to clarify that
i'm a big fan of the free state project
we're going shooting saturday come with
us yes
we're getting vaccines
different kind of shooting
and we're going to bring barbecue down
right we bring barbecue did i get your
barbecue today he did from terry black i
haven't had it yet he's amazing blair
you're going to bring your pink ar i can
do that yeah
she's got one
i got barbecue for you uh i want to go
to the woods with you though because i
asked thursday too
i know it's so we're going to get it
we're going to go down and we want
rudy's we'll get that
we should yeah we could do it so
whatever so you think like a statewide
um school choice initiative is where the
net is the next step of god is
shattering them all sounds good
i think we need a national free state
kind of thing yes we need people at the
local level to start voting only for
their local candidates who agree with
certain principles of freedom liberty
individual responsibility i agree we
need a litmus test for liberals
conservatives gay straight whatever do
you support the bill of rights the
constitution everybody's rights let's
get past yeah later who's gonna be put
this is nonsense who's going to be
putting this litmus test into practice
they do it if you do it in new hampshire
new hampshire has the highest amount of
homeschoolers per capita than the entire
the united states they have some of the
highest iq they have this they have some
of
them
stop stop yeah
i've talked to gay people straight
people black people they all want
freedom no they don't you're full of
[ __ ] because you saw what happened with
the lockdowns if they all wanted freedom
we wouldn't have the lockdown that's a
complete lie stop the lockdowns what did
we stop lord stop the lockdown yeah wait
no am i going to why are you so
pessimistic i'm not pessimistic because
i'm thinking if you think the salvation
is going to be voting in the right
people you're completely devotional
culturally fight it every time alex
voting is one aspect alex he's talking
about the lemmings the millions of
lemmings in this country that bend the
knee into the globally answer the
constitution
what do we do about them and they don't
want freedom you have to create systems
that work around them
is what we do which means non-democratic
systems yeah i think what does that mean
non-democratic meaning systems that
don't depend on getting majority of
simpletons to agree with you no i agree
if i'm a republican in the republic
if 51 percent want to enslave me they
don't have it right
but if it's 85 it doesn't matter i don't
care how many peop how popular it is my
rights are not up for discussion let
alone a vote and luke the reason i was
disagreeing with you is so bad mouse i
am mad because there's a war in our
minds the what i was disagree with you
about luke is new hampshire is a
self-sufficient population it's a very
small population you can't replicate the
free state project on a nationwide level
because there's a huge percent of the
population as you agree with who does
not view do not share our values i
disagree because if you look at just
autonomy i don't care if it's a bunch of
communists wanting to live in the woods
we have examples of this with the amish
the amish are living by their own set of
rules without government they're not
mandates without vaccine mandates and
they're and they're doing a lot better
than a lot of other people so if the i'm
not no
that's not true no no they are dealing
with they're dealing with but but they
haven't had a significant cheryl
atkinson's did a great documentary about
this yeah it's on our youtube channel
it's great they are dealing with kovid
uh you guys are both right and i think
you're right much slower
but but they don't have a huge death
rate like many people expect it to even
though they have policies where they
literally drink from the same cup they
have religious ceremonies where and
everyone said the amish are going to die
the amish are going to have a huge
extinction event that didn't happen
their death rate has stayed the same
with kovid comparatively to the rest of
the population so that's a big thing
cheryl atkinson's documentary is really
huge here and if the amish could do it
the free state project could do it and
that's victory in itself that's victory
when people say hey i just want to have
my own kind of life my own rules my own
autonomy
tyranny non-compliance
and new hampshire it has created a
beacon for bitcoin has created a beacon
for personal responsibility for personal
freedom from homeschooling it's becoming
the shining light and example of people
coming together and saying hey this is
how i want to live you can live there
and if people want to be communist let
them go to new york
i have an administrative thing to
announce to the people listening um
for the super chats at a certain point
youtube just starts the leading super
chats so we we we can read some of them
but
uh
i just i just want to say next i feel
bad for a lot of people who are you know
posting comments and questions
when you have a show this big with 110
plus i think like 114 or 15 000 people
watching it one more time yeah
youtube just basically starts erasing
the super chats thank you everyone
to the channel you can live in new york
city you could live in los angeles or
you could live in new hampshire i live
in new hampshire because that's how i
choose luke i moved to austin for this
reason yeah you're preaching to the
choir why are you camifornia but you
moved to the new come before you know
where all the trendies are sure
the point is you were tim and alex were
asking how do we replicate this
nationwide and all i'm saying is you
can't replicate the free state project
nationwide because there's not enough
people to make that happen
democratically no i disagree um
you we were just talking about how uh so
who was mentioning this the primaries
basically dictate how all the elections
are being run okay are we talking about
this i don't think we were but the idea
is that you get a small small amount of
people who will uh vote for a democrat
and then mo uh independents basically
don't like they don't participate in
primaries so they uh they enter the
election and they're like what are my
choices whatever the democrat 10 and the
republican 10 voted for what happens if
you get a free state project of you got
a state with a million people or you got
you got a jurisdiction of a million
people and a hundred thousand are
liberty-minded people who are brought
together and they all say we are all
going to vote in the republican primary
for this libertarian and then the
independent moderates exactly
that takes over that's a trump one
i mean it's how the progressive it's how
aoc won yeah nobody actually knows
what she was i feel like i'm crazy
there's an enormous asymmetry because
when you have those two candidates
whoever that libertarian candidate is
will be demonized by the corporate press
that backfires now know what
biden won
by fraud yeah i think you're right that
we need a non-democratic solution
steve bannon
the the this is i'll tell you what the
most okay well he wouldn't win right now
i don't think he'd win right now but the
most frustrating they won two seats in
georgia they write an article explaining
about the shadow campaign to save the
election they talk about mail-in voting
and how it gave them massive advantages
over republicans and then you end up
with this large populist movement
spinning in circles about things they
haven't proven in a year and then
instead of getting their ground game
going and countering the changes to
election law they're going around
screaming at each other about tim's
right i engaged him in a reset war i'm
trying to get people to realize is there
a website for that alex the corporation
is creating
reset wars.com
the point is it's the biggest thing i'm
doing it's going to launch next month
it's huge but what sure i've changed the
world a lot here so i'm not a bser this
is big stuff how do we get people aware
of the global corporate structure how
their mind controlling us
instead of just receiving the propaganda
we've got a big awakened population
right now how do we get them engaged
i would say build a decentralized
parallel system and i'll give it to you
also well i'll say i'll say it's you do
ridiculous things like this yes you know
i was like hey we're into a really
really crazy show
navigate the minefields the best of your
abilities so
they don't you know chop the tree down
before it's a chance to bear fruit and i
will say um free state like ideas it's
not perfect but i think new hampshire is
doing something something very very
powerful and positive and
i gotta tell you if we're gonna if we're
going to have any victories like what
new hampshire is doing is very
interesting and it can be done in other
states a small mine a small minority of
politically active individuals can over
like look at the mises caucus i know the
libertarian party is not when dave smith
gets 15 of the democrat of the of the
polling numbers in 2024 and i'm the
press secretary for that campaign
getting 15 to polls is not impossible
and then things are really gonna get fun
and then what happens is you may be in
the minority but most people will just
vote for one or the other and if you're
the alternative to the corrupt machine
where the right people are ready to vote
for a ham sandwich you're there so
here's what i want to say
so right now one of the things that
bothers me the most we had steve bannon
on this show and i think he's a very
smart guy and we we did a members only
segment where we talked about fraud and
he's adamant in his belief and i said
take a look at uh universal mail in
voting take a look this is why i believe
there is no fraud and i believe it's a
red herring that has manipulated the
populists into totally losing their
standing and grounding and their ability
to to win these these battles because
you have in a democrat city one look at
new york you get one housing complex
with 500 units they all get five
universal mail-in bouts for the five
people who live their mom dad and their
2.5 kids
the democrat sends one activist to go
door-to-door and hits 500 families times
five votes each and they can do that in
a couple days just knocking on doors if
they make their web and they say this
did you vote yet your ballot is right
there fill it out i'll wait republicans
have to go to rural areas where they
drive
through suburbs and they can hit five
houses on one block and they can get 10
houses in a day republicans should focus
on cities republicans should focus on
the rule changes that heavily advantage
urban dense centers the republicans
should focus on the rule changes that
disadvantaged republicans instead what
are we getting trump's movement the
populists are right now
they're talking about
venezuela and china and gun battles in
germany and i'm like totally they got
them they shut them down with the
conspiracy fraud stuff and now because
donald trump won in 2016 with 77 000
votes across three states sure he did
really well in the electoral college but
it was 77 000 votes across three states
and so they said if we can throw the
populist movement off base with
something that won't have an impact on
us we won't lose again and they did it
a year before the 2020 election the
republicans in pennsylvania changed the
law to introduce universal mail-in
voting we talked with sean parnell about
this he sued about this they said
at first we're going to create universal
mailing voting uh oh our constitution
forbids it and they stopped because they
needed a constitutional amendment to
enact it they stopped and said okay what
do we do let's change the word to mail
instead of absentee and pass it anyway
and when sean when sean parnell and
others sued over this because it was an
unconstitutional change a lower court
judge said on the merits you will likely
win
it went to a higher court who said
for for it not on the merits just for
standing or for it's too late i forgot
the the the the latin word for two
latest they said we're not gonna take
the case so we see an article that in
time magazine the shadow campaign to win
to save the election and they explain
exactly what they did we changed all the
rules to heavily advantage dense urban
centers and then
republicans got not republicans but the
populists got wrapped up in a fraud
narrative that stopped them from there's
a whole book about this there's a whole
book about it let me just say one
sentence alex
there's a whole book about this called
rigged by molly hemingway i know you had
uh mark on the show to discuss this so
people are interested they can read
about it go ahead alex no i'm just gonna
say
where does this all in we're about to be
at war with china the dollar's plunging
there's massive inflation let's talk
about the big picture what is the
american people going to do
as they realize that the design
collapses here
and that all these corporate interests
think we're too stupid to understand
what's happening to me that's the big
deal forget trump forget democrats
forget you know all this stuff we are in
a major sea change right now
alex i think being happy healthy and
prepared for whatever comes next is the
solution is the real resistance yes and
there's going to be a lot of turmoil
especially economically hitting this
country as soon as covet happened i was
like this is not going to be about covet
this is going to be about the economy
and we're seeing the the start of this
this is only the beginning of this and i
think we're really headed for hard times
and i think the way to resist this is by
having family is by having a network is
by having a cohesive group together that
is ready for whatever happens if you're
unprepared you're weighing down your
family you're weighing down your
neighborhood you're weighing down your
community so right now more than ever
smarten up look at the situation that's
happening in front of you and make sure
that you are ready for whatever's to
come because it's going to go it's going
to be a very bumpy ride i totally agree
with that we should just transcend all
the arguments and realize this is a
global engineer collapse yes it is
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time